foreign
I'm curious to know because I I have
experienced
incredible
well let's see I'm there may be
trade-offs but benefits with respect to
Onset insomnia from low dose
edible
I could say cannabis but in this case
you know we're talking about in legal
settings where state governments allow
this say 2.5 milligrams of THC
with CBD it just takes too high I mean I
would have to consume just kind of a
mountain of it for it to for it to
subjectively help with that what are the
trade-offs if any with dosages in that
range if you're aware yeah it depends on
who you are so I did an episode on
cannabis I also had on our mutual friend
Nolan Williams who's a one of these
freaks of nature he's a triple board
certified psychiatrist neurologist
neurologist at Stanford underachiever a
real underachiever doing a lot on
combination of psychedelics with
transcranial magnetic stimulation talked
about cannabis and ideas solo episode on
cannabis which means basically all I did
was think about read about and talk to
people about cannabis for months on end
here's a story with cannabis it's as you
pointed out it's going to be the ratio
of THC to CBD that's important and for
the real aficionados out there and boy
are they out there because they let me
know they are there's also the terpenes
they're going to be the lemon-like
terpenes and the other kinds of terpenes
and chemicals in these things that are
also going to matter and then also it's
going to be smoking vaping
edible or tincture those are gonna be
the
so here's the deal smoking or vaping
anything is bad nicotine or cannabis or
worse for you than edible or tincture
let's just move that off to the side
high THC concentration cannabis of which
now there is almost pure THC cannabis
available
is dangerous for the following reason
and there I just pissed off some people
but first of all it does have
therapeutic applications for glaucoma
pain management maybe even some mental
health facts ability to help people
certain people focus at low dose
but for
in particular young males in their teens
early teens and 20s who take high THC
containing cannabis there is a much
greater like 4X increase in probability
of psychotic episodes later that don't
ever reverse in fact when I spoke to the
leading researcher on this up in Canada
she told me that the probability that
a lot of what we see is kind of Street
homelessness now what people appear to
be schizophrenic was likely triggered by
high-dose cannabis use now I'm not
trying to return us to the 1960s and
talk about Devil's weed and this kind of
thing it is clear that cannabis has
therapeutic benefits but very high
potency THC cannabis can be a problem at
the dosage you described 2.5 milligrams
very unlikely to be a problem now
psychologically psychologically and I
mean I could be on 2.5 I'm not but I
could be on 2.5 right now and it would
be it would not be some perceptible dose
it's kind of like micro dose I would
feel it but it would not be externally
obvious now the pure CBD cannabis is
interesting too so-called Charlotte's
Web I think is what's called mainly
available in Colorado I'm told
is a powerful
anti-epileptic in fact parents of
epileptic kids moved to Colorado just so
they can get Charlotte's Web CBD
cannabis in my mind that should be
available legally everywhere given that
is essentially no psychoactive effects
yeah there are a few perhaps but so it's
really that the percentage of THC
relatives to CBD that's important the
age of the user whether or not there's a
predisposition of psychosis you know we
might as well be talking about
psychedelics right might as well you're
talking about psyched dogs and I want to
just pause for a second to say
a few things number one I don't
categorize MDMA as a psychedelic we may
get to that but just for a number of
semantic and phenomenological like a
fancy reasons I don't classify that as a
psychedelic and I would actually
categorize high THC content cannabis as
a strong potential psychedelic and it
has become I would just say the standard
the Baseline of strength has become such
a multiple of what anyone might have
been used to in say the 90s it is almost
beyond belief and I do know of one
direct example
this is the brother of an acquaintance
who had exactly the experience you're
describing which is
chronic short-term but chronic use of
very high TC concentration cannabis and
I should say In fairness that classical
psychedelics can also
spedite the onset of schizophrenic
symptoms and those who would genetically
be predisposed so it's it's not limited
to THC but it is I think under
respected and
overused with the assumption that it's
just cannabis and that's I think that's
a mistake it's a very they can be so
powerfully psychoactive yeah it's
interesting how the the proponents of
cannabis which there are a lot of smart
people in cannabis medicine including a
lot of MDS
always say it's not as bad as alcohol
which to me is just a ridiculous
argument I mean just say that something
is not as bad as alcohol implies that
you know you have to choose one or the
other
I think that cannabis has been very
beneficial for a number of adults who
are through the so-called critical
period of brain plasticity so older than
they need some way to go take the edge
off in the evening they'll do an edible
on the weekend this kind of thing that
is not what we're talking about in terms
of psychosis we're talking about kids 12
13 14 taking a you know like a bong rip
or smoking a joint or vaping a super
high potency THC containing cannabis and
just being high out of their gourd and
feeling like it was a really good time
doing that two or three times and then
and I seen this over and over again
their parents reach out to me often in
fact
for whatever reason and then you hear
about this person being 17 18 there's a
failure to launch component they're a
motivated they're claiming ADHD they're
busy A Stoner who relies on cannabis to
relieve anxiety and
hasn't done much else in the last five
years and or certainly has not managed
to keep up with the mean and you know
and here I'm sympathetic by the way this
is listening to somebody who barely
finished high school we covered that in
the last podcast so you know for other
reasons
but I do worry a lot about these super
high potency compounds I worry about
super high potency anything I mean I
worry about in the realm of of hormone
augmentation we're talking fedojia
tongar Ali not Diana ball you know in
the realm of of augmenting mood and
focus we're comparing very high potency
THC containing cannabis taken in a youth
to
300 milligrams of alpha GPC this is
night and day right it's chemical
augmentation of a completely different
Beast so I think that it's clear that no
cannabis is going to be better for most
people than any cannabis is occasionally
used for an adult going to be a problem
probably not yeah probably not I will
we'll also say add to that a few things
number one
I am deeply interested in the
therapeutic applications of cannabis and
all of its constituent Parts I think it
is uh
very undervalued
plant from that perspective and I think
it is is severely underestimated in
terms of potency
just the standard available
particularly in in places where you can
kind of get the baker's dozen
of any number of strains beta Colorado
Etc it's
to believe that you are using something
of almost no risk as compared to
psychedelics
if it's if it contains a lot of THC is a
mistake
so I would just say
consider it on par with some of these
very strong psychedelics and
just be informed and be cautious about
your use I I do think
that there are probably some really
significant applications to
Sleep disorders and I will add just for
people listening I have also tried
CBN specifically which has been
recommended to me for sleep and have not
found it as effective it probably
depends on the specific variety of sleep
disorder but for onset insomnia that is
a product predominantly not of Spike
glucose or I guess cortisol and or then
glucose levels but rather rumination
THC seems to be one of the magic keys in
very low doses